sieht sehr appetitlich aus heute schaut
mal geht auf jeden fall geil aus der
logistik fast ganz willkommen beim ein
video ich hoffe euch jetzt gut ich habe
ja ungefähr vor drei wochen versucht
wirklich eine woche nur süßigkeiten zu
essen hat nicht so ganz geklappt das
habe ich glaube ich nach drei oder vier
tage abgebrochen aber ich habe euch halt
noch unter dem video gefragt ob ich
vielleicht mal eine woche vegan leben
sollte weil da habe ich echt mega bock
drauf und ich glaube der kommentare 3000
like sooo und daraus habe ich dann jetzt
geschlossen dass jeder bottroper als
richtig sagen vegane woche beginnt jetzt
wir haben gerade montag und wir gehen
jetzt erst mal einkaufen ein paar schöne
vegane sachen kaufen die man so nebenbei
essen kann und ich würde sagen dann gehe
ich jeden abend halt einfach mal vegan
essen schaue was es hier so gibt ich
kenne mich null aus was vegan angeht
hier gibt es auf jeden fall vieles in
köln
ich weiß auch ungefähr wo aber was das
so genau ist kein plan was ich noch kurz
sagen wollte wir haben nämlich echt sehr
sehr viele leute geschrieben vor allem
nach dem pizza video er alex macht doch
bitte einfach mal eine woche mcdonald's
und guck was passiert und ich habe mich
erst nicht so getraut das zu machen aber
ich bekomme das halt mittlerweile immer
noch andauernd geschickt und deswegen
würde ich sagen ich sag einfach mal so
bei 25.000 likes mache ich das in
zukunft auch mal dann kommt eine woche
macdonald ich kann nicht versprechen
dass ich eine woche wirklich nur
macdonald erste wahl wenn es mir scheiße
da durchgeht
ich muss natürlich auch zur uni und
sonst was dann kann ich das nicht weiter
durchziehen
aber ich kann versuchen also wenn ihr
wirklich so mega bock gehabt dass noch
nach oben
dann sehe ich das ja und jetzt viel spaß
mit dem video metzger wir gehen uns erst
mal einkaufen und so leute auf geht's
zum veganen laden ich bin wirklich sehr
gespannt ob es der leckere sachen gibt
aber bestimmte leute dieser vegane laden
spaß sie ist irgendwo im nirgendwo ich
habe keine ahnung wo wir sind und wir
müssen jetzt locken
oslo ich habe eigentlich gedacht und
können gibt es echt mehr vegane
ausfallen also das muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagen
einfach zu ganz klar wir sind jetzt
locker keine ahnung eine dreiviertel
stunde haben wir gebraucht ist hier hin
ich hatte einfach zu im internet schon
bis 22 uhr
ohne spaß
wir sind hier
im deutschen winter vegane laden hatte
zu haben wir noch einen salatkopf
beginnt mein okay ich hab jetzt nicht so
einen riesenhunger hier habe ich jetzt
noch ein paar früchte drin das ist dann
halt so etwa okay man gucken morgen geht
dahin wo ich mir was und sie uns so
leute was gedacht und morgen
wir gehen jetzt zu diesem laden und
versuchen unser glück noch mal wo bin
ich denn hier gelandet
ohne spaß leute ich habe noch nie so ein
laden gesehen sogar diese teile wenn man
halt seine ware auf der kasse von den
anderen abtrennt typischen hat es heute
so richtige holt klumpen wichtig wird
aber vegane sachen sind auch echt teuer
ich mein kapitän mario vier euro bezahlt
alles gleichzeitig das gleich mal zurück
zu hause ja man endlich alter das ist so
schwer wiegt nämlich am donnerstag nach
berlin
und genau an diesen tagen ist in berlin
der messe und ich hab mir jetzt ein
hotel gebucht und das hier ist jetzt das
vierte hotel was endlich in klassischen
bücher auf jeden fall passen auch als
schnell gekauft werden wir haben wir
zunächst einmal vegane brötchen da haben
wir veganer geflügelwurst dann haben wir
vegane hafer cookies und ein veganes
getränk der ehrliche huber beste zutaten
100 prozent bio vegan eine vegane
schokolade für drei euro und hier vegane
arjouni superlecker hoffe ich zumindest
also an sich macht sich alisa jahre und
vegane nachos das sollte jetzt auf jeden
fall erstmal für die nächsten zwei tage
reichen oder für die nächsten
zweieinhalb tage weil zum beispiel heute
abend gehe ich im restaurant und es
irgendwas veganes indem ich natürlich
mit aber ich muss jetzt erst mal zur uni
so leute gefallen ist in die stadt und
ich bestelle mir einen veganen burrito
politisch auf jeden fall so mein
lieblingsessen hier in köln und nennen
vegan brite habe ich noch nie probiert
deswegen let's go
erstmalig und
von gut
also man muss sagen der brite hatte auf
jeden fall mehr gut geschmeckt vor allem
so ein bisschen fertig ich hatte keine
ahnung was genau das immer aber man kann
das weite
so leute bevor ich schlafen gehe ich
habe mir gedacht ich muss eigentlich
noch mal kurz diese kekse probieren ich
habe nämlich noch ein bisschen hunger
und vegane keks habe ich halt ein
anliegen gewesen also die riechen kann
nicht mal so schlecht
also um ehrlich zu sein die strecke
nicht für ganz normale kekse geschmeckt
jetzt keinen unterschied kann man nicht
essen also ich dachte bis jetzt wirklich
immer so vegan das kannst du niemals
machen also du kannst niemals so ohne
burger oder so leben aber ehrlich zu
sein jetzt zum beispiel burrito oder
jetzt auch die kekse das ist wirklich
lecker das kann man erst mal das absolut
gut dann morgen so leid ich bin jetzt zu
hause es ist wirklich einfach so waren
hier deswegen habe ich nichts anderes so
zumindest bevor wir es gleich was essen
gehen wollte ich einfach mal kurz ein
paar nazis ausprobieren mit dem veganen
aioli dip und auch mal die schokolade
probieren einfach so alles lag
zwischendurch weil ich meine skeptischen
noch veganen kuchen aber keine ahnung wo
unsere passend zum nachmittag macht das
hier auf jeden fall sind so ich fange
jetzt einfach mal den abschluss an die
richtlinien wie sonnenfeld da ist mehr
drin und das schmeckt original mehr
gekümmert
also sowie richtiges arjouni wie ich das
jetzt nicht hier
vegan mal probieren und ich bin
irgendwie fällt erstmals von mehr
gespannt auf diese schokolade
ich finde zu einer vernünftigen
schokolade grad hat schon mich irgendwie
dazu
deswegen bin ich mal gespannt auch hier
nochmal vegan wie die schnecke
[Musik]
mit viel mut kann man immer ein bisschen
teurer
so leute wie wir jetzt den veganen
burger testen ich habe gehört dass ein
mega gut schmecken
ich habe keine ahnung wo das ist aber
irgendwo hier mit diesen tieren ein
begann dann nicht zusammenkriegen
ich meine ich mich drauf setzte es geht
könnte auch seinen kopf hin zum kitsch
mein kollege wollte sich hast du gesagt
baugleicher gibt's winzen mettbrötchen
und entsteht dass der winter ja auch das
ist mir egal
hierauf diesem keller ist alles vegan
sogar dass da
50 m das ist ok so leute ich habe darauf
vergessen war auf jeden fall okay würde
ich mal sagen also ich hab schon
deutlich bessere vergessen aber man kann
es auf jeden fall essen und die ganzen
anderen wir gerne im laden das waren
alles so wie es die freude zu uns also
das war echt sondern schöne atmosphäre
dies empfand
so laut ich bin jetzt wieder zurück zu
hause das ist jetzt schon irgendwie 11
uhr ich muss jetzt erstmal meinen koffer
packen weil morgen geht es los nach
berlin auf jeden fall packe ich jetzt
schnell danke ich duschen und dann
wollte ich noch mal hier
jesus getränk probieren vorm
schlafengehen so leute fertig geduldig
für sagen wir probieren mal eben dieses
vegane zeug also ein schönes kühles
getränk vorm schlafengehen die erste
alkohol drin bin nicht dumm check das
jetzt erst es gibt ja natürlich hugo
also man kennt ja diesen hugo diesen
sekt und ich dachte das heißt einfach so
nur hugo aber das ist halt veganer hugo
mit 5,8 prozent alkohol aber vegan kann
ich jetzt einbringen
eigentlich ja nicht mit ein schluck nur
den rest trinke ich natürlich nicht wert
also ich muss ehrlich sagen ich hasse
jede art von sekt es schmeckt einfach
nicht aber das hier schmeckt ganz gut
das hat mich diese nächtlichen
nachgeschmack
okay man nicht leute unter 16 bringt ihr
sowas nicht ganz klar ich wünsche euch
eine angenehme wir sehen uns morgen rein
darf ich auch was von meiner wegen
schokolade zum frühstück anbieten
nein ich glaube nicht dass ich habe mich
super richtig
berlin los geht
leute was gehe ich erst mal ich bin mega
mega fertig bin jetzt endlich angekommen
ich werde jetzt keine mega fete grün
zumachen
auf jeden fall ich muss euch erstmal das
gestehen ich habe heute morgen was
gegessen und dann bin ich geflogen und
ich hatte schon mega mega hunger hab
dann gedacht er kommen dass schaafs noch
bin zum flughafen gefahren und dann hat
er meinen schläger einfach zwei stunden
verspätungen am flughafen gab es nix
veganes und im flieger musste ich dann
einfach ein käsebrot essen also es war
jetzt nicht ganz legal da bin ich auch
ganz ehrlich aber besser als wenn ich
euch jetzt an lügen würde und ich bin da
einfach so mega müde
ich habe zum glück noch sie es sich
jetzt erstmal später gehen wir dann mal
raus und guck mal was ist hier so
veganes wird und jetzt muss ich mich
eigentlich erst mal eine halbe stunde
hinlegen weil dann bin ich wieder fit
ich habe gerade geduscht deswegen sind
männer ich mache ich wenn ich muss sagen
dass ich wirklich erst als ich habe echt
mega man uhr und um ehrlich zu sein die
schmecken echt gut ich bin mal wieder
positiv überrascht haben veganen
lifestyle
obwohl ich jetzt natürlich viel lieber
irgendwas richtig richtig leckeres hätte
so leute das hier sind veganer nudeln
mit tomatensoße und keine ahnung was
sehr appetitlich aus es ist ein grafiker
dass wir jetzt einfach das nicht
[Applaus]
na klar
schmeckt ist ein
veganer
dann nämlich die bei ungesund was
probieren
so leute was geht ab herzlich willkommen
ich wollte mal guten morgen möchte ich
sagen wir waren gestern noch ein
bisschen unterwegs deswegen haben wir
jetzt schon 15 ich habe mir da nichts
gegessen
wir gehen jetzt im mégane ich habe heute
alles super
da wird es allerdings ein alex zweite
vorname überwogen aber auf jeden fall
wir sind hier auf jeden fall mit in
berlin sehr gute lage deswegen letzte
mal gucken was geht von alex halte die
können ja vor über die rein gucken die
leute gucken also ich will nicht
einlagern jetzt gab es vielleicht schaut
alex klärt gerade für uns veganen
bonn
ich bin so gespannt ob ich das mag schon
einen veganen aber ganz
heute schaut mal geht auf jeden fall
geil aus
[Musik]
hallo dass wir das geld
die nutzer mainz oder auf
vegan schwimmend auf jeden fall genug
sich auch sehr gesund aus alles was hier
wieder auch einfach mal so gesund aus
schmeckt echt das t shirt gefällt mir
nicht so so wird auf geht's nach hause
so leute was geht herzlich willkommen
warum es eigentlich immer herzlich
willkommen ich bin auf jeden fall zu
hause und ich habe mir nicht von
vornherein gedacht bevor ich das ganze
ab schließe ich muss auf jeden fall noch
mal diesen veggie burger von mcdonald
probiert deswegen habe ich meine eltern
gegen rad mitgebracht auf jeden fall ich
weiß natürlich der käse ist nicht vegan
denke ich mal und das brötchen weiß ich
nicht ich glaube auch mit allerdings ist
das jetzt die letzte mahlzeit der ganzen
woche und ja ich wollte einfach mal
ausprobieren weil es mich interessiert
ich hoffe ihr nehmt mir das nicht übel
schmeckt gleich wieder überraschend gut
geschützt irgendwie weiß nicht ich hätte
das niemals gedacht also vielleicht für
die zukunft wollt euch nicht immer bei
fast food restaurants ein cheeseburger
sondern vielleicht auch mal ein hippie
bürger zum abschluss vielleicht doch ein
kurzes resümee von der ganzen woche also
vielleicht erstmal ist manchmal echt
wirklich schwer immer aufzunehmen wird
das ganze fest zu halten weil ich weiß
wie letzte woche ziemlich viel unterwegs
dann muss halt auch immer irgendwann
finden damit die essen geht oder damit
die ersten bestellt oder der weiß wo ein
veganer laden ist das war echt mega mega
schwer vorher in berlin zum beispiel
kann ich mich auch fast gar nicht aus
aber ich fand es wirklich cool das war
ein cooles experiment meiner meinung
nach und ich habe jetzt auf
nahrungsmittel vielleicht noch mal eine
etwas andere sichtweise dass es nicht
immer einen burger sein muss wo fleisch
drauf ist oder das ist immer irgendwie
was sein muss was mit fleisch zu tun hat
es gibt auch echte menge vegane sachen
die man wirklich wirklich gut essen kann
die lecker schmecken natürlich habe ich
jetzt auch ein paar mal was gegessen wo
ich dachte das kannst du niemals als
ersatzmann für irgendwas anderes zum
beispiel gestern in berlin an diesem
vegan laden das war echt nicht so lecker
aber so ist das halt also leute ich
hoffe dass wieder hat euch gefallen wie
schon gesagt weil 25.000 likes machen
war eine woche macdonald wenn ich mal
gespannt und wir sehen uns dann morgen
wieder morgen kommt das neue videos
sowie das jetzt wieder länger nichts kam
aber nicht wieder dabei ich muss mal
gerade auch mega viel lernen ist mega
stress ich gerade alles ich wünschte
eine schöne woche haut rein